these dudes were too stressed out and I got to remind them this is literate all we have to do today is play a basketball game that takes up two hours am I supposed to be talking since the cameras on me right now we have to get a handshake eventually take it to the rack look at that over the top yup he's grabbing you know he was Z you smell like cool water Cologne cool water I smell like cheap aftershave yeah cool water yes he'll inside Sloat's mr. tap tap video be aggressive everybody sits next to me at some point I kind of like to move if we're winning I'll sit in the same spot for losing I usually move go to take your time no my by yourself yup that's the hook point of emphasis shoot I mean he didn't want that come on down here you look like an R&B artist I don't know which one you look like [Applause] no we didn't know again yeah now I gotta go to work no he did [Applause]